[Música]
y
la edición número 72 del premio emmy y
va a ser única va a ser virtual la
primera vez en la historia que se
realice sin público dónde van a estar
los que van a recibir el premio dando
unas palabras pero sin público en el
auditorio el presentador nuevamente va a
ser jenny ki-moon que se espera no se
sabe qué tipo de chiste o de humor vaya
a tener por todo lo que estamos viviendo
sobre todo aquí en california los
fuertes incendios los peores de la
historia la pandemia el desempleo
entonces no da como para hacer muchos
chistes esa es una de las incógnitas de
esta ceremonia además esta ceremonia ha
sido fuertemente criticada porque llega
en un momento en que si se tiene que
reactivar la economía pero los violentos
incendios y todo lo que está pasando en
california pues no da como para realizar
este tipo de homenajes a la actuación en
la pantalla chica la alfombra roja por
supuesto también va a ser virtual
[Música]
por supuesto este año la semana de la
moda en nueva york no ha tenido nada que
ver con ediciones anteriores los
desfiles virtuales han sido los grandes
protagonistas en una plataforma digital
presentada por la propia organización y
en la que los diseñadores han tenido que
tirar de imaginación para mantener la
atención de los asistentes de los
espectadores que en la mayoría de los
casos han seguido estos desfiles desde
sus propias casas aunque hemos visto
algún diseñador que ha querido abandonar
el formato virtual y celebrar un desfile
al uso como por ejemplo jason wu eso sí
en un espacio con asistencia limitada
distanciamiento social y mascarillas
obligatorias en un sitio donde en una
situación normal habría cerca de 1000
personas pero este año ha sido con
asistencia mucho más reducida el último
día de la new york fashion week tampoco
ha tenido nada que ver con ediciones
anteriores no hemos contado con grandes
diseñadores como michael kors eso sí el
cierre ha venido de la mano del
diseñador estadounidense christian
siriano que ha querido presentar su
colección desde el jardín de su casa
para todos
y que por supuesto también se podía
seguir de manera virtual
[Música]
con un concierto benéfico online que
podrá verse por el canal de youtube el
cantante y compositor de música pop mica
de origen libanés ha querido dar un poco
de esperanza a los libaneses devastados
por la tragedia del puerto aunque
prácticamente ha vivido toda su vida en
inglaterra mica nació en beirut y se
rompió el corazón cuando vio las
imágenes devastadoras de la explosión
que ocurrió exactamente detrás de donde
me encuentro en el silo del puerto los
beneficios de las entradas irán
directamente a ongs internacionales para
destinarlos a la reconstrucción de
beirut la explosión fue tan devastadora
que los daños son incalculables pero las
autoridades libanesas siguen enfrascadas
en sus rivalidades sectarias en vez de
formar gobierno y que es uno de los
requisitos necesarios para poder tener
las ayudas internacionales
[Música]